[Music]
hey everyone welcome to my 2021 work
from home desktop tour where i'm going
to be showing you where i spend most of
my time working studying and making
youtube videos so i was never really
someone who cared about having a clean
desk with multiple monitors and a proper
chair you know mechanical keyboards and
all that i just kind of sat around the
house in random places doing my work but
as we spend more and more time at home
now i realized how important creating a
proper work environment was when it came
to improving productivity and just being
able to focus without too many
distractions
and so over the past five months i've
watched dozens of videos where youtubers
share their desk setups and i got really
inspired by how much thought and effort
was put into them i decided to give it a
go myself and i can say i'm pretty proud
of the end result so let's jump right
into the video and i'll show you around
alright so as we walk into the room the
first thing you'll see is my desk i
bought this desk from amazon and it's
the artist's standing desk and there
were quite a few table tops to choose
from what i really like about this desk
though is that it can adjust to a pretty
decent height
which is really good because i'm pretty
tall but you can save up to five heights
and easily switch between them i would
say this was a pretty good purchase for
me because i don't think i can ever go
back to just using a normal desk again i
kind of need this stand option so i can
see myself using this desk for a long
time now let's move on to what i have on
my desk so to power up my workstation i
use this macbook pro and this was sent
to me by work so i use this for my day
to day tasks editing videos and just
everything work related i also have a
personal laptop that i use for
everything non-work related like
watching movies playing games all that
and if i ever want to switch between the
two i just plug it in the monotop and
i'll be able to use that instead so for
my laptop stand i decided to get this 12
south book arc and you can prop your
laptop in here oops the wrong way around
you can pop it in here and
it can sit quite nicely on the desk i
think it looks quite aesthetic it's
quite sleek a bit overpriced in my
opinion
but i think the only other negative part
to it is that your laptop is clamped
shut so you can't really do video calls
without having an external webcam since
i don't have an external webcam i need
to just open up the laptop while i do my
video course so i won't be able to use
this all the time next i have this
keyboard and mouse
so the keyboard is the keychron k2 at
the start when i was using it i was
getting a lot of wrist pain and my hands
are hurting because it's too high so i
wouldn't recommend this for people who
just want to get this keyboard by itself
what i had to do was i had to buy this
extra wrist rest and i've been having no
pain or any troubles with the keyboard
ever since it's pretty good because it
has a nice sound to it
and i bought the one that sounds the
most quiet so that during my work cause
and everything i'm not going to be
distracting everyone else this mouse was
one of the cheapest wireless mouse i
could find by logitech and i got this
off amazon and i didn't really find the
need to buy one of those fancy
mouse's nice mouse that have a lot more
extra functionalities my favorite item
on the desk by far is this dboom tv max
and this is essentially a bluetooth
speaker but it has so many more
functionalities and one of my favorite
functionalities is the fact that it can
display some pixel art i can connect it
to my phone and select the artwork i
want there's thousands of artworks to
choose from and you can also create your
own so pretty cool i really like it
because i can just choose any image i
want put it down on the side and it's
something nice to have beside me as i do
my day-to-day tasks
so for multiple screens and a bigger
display i decided to go with these two
dell monitors and also a vivo monitor
arm i actually got these two monitors
for free because they came with my
amazon internship but i decided to get a
monitor mount so that i can have these
two monitors side by side and for it to
have more of a floating effect moving on
to the next thing on my desk this is a
t2 water bottle and it specifically is
designed to put tea leaves inside and
you can pour hot water and it's double
insulated by glass i really like it i
think it's quite
portable and it's
it's able to keep
water or tea quite warm next we have
this little plant i think i got it from
kmart like five six years ago
there's nothing
really useful about this i think it just
adds a bit of a nice touch we have these
coasters
there's four of them i probably only
need one at a time to be honest 70 from
amazon probably not really worth the
cost
but i think it looks really nice on the
desk it adds a really nice touch to it
it's very similar to this plant except
this plant was only like three dollars
but yeah really like it and whenever i
have a jug of hot water or anything like
that i can just put it on top of the
coasters and that way it won't be able
to leave any marks on my desk next i
have this wireless rechargeable lamp you
can change the color just by tapping on
it it's rgb
you can also use a remote control to
control the colors even further but i
think i lost the remote but yeah it was
25 and i think it was pretty worth the
price and i recommend getting it linked
in the description below i also have
this wireless charger which i really
like because i can just prop my phone
directly on it and be able to use the
face id without having to take it off or
get distracted something else on my desk
that i really like are these sony
wireless headphones these are noise
cancelling and yeah i can't really hear
myself anymore but i use this when
listening to music and also for watching
videos not only for video course because
i wanted to just use something wired
something simple and also i want to be
able to hear myself during the course
but this is really good for listening to
music and booking out noise when i need
to i also have these printed daily
planner sheets
and i was always trying to find a really
good tracking system to plan out my days
and i've tried all sorts of online
methods you know lotion all of that it
just never really worked for me because
i prefer pen and paper a bit extra but
what i did was i designed this on canva
so i included the day
urgent not urgent for tomorrow and long
term and i also have a daily highlight
so as long as i get whatever is on my
daily highlight done i'll feel like
that's a productive day on my desk
there's also this huge
mouse desk pad that's
double sided so
red and black and this keeps my desk
from getting dirty because i'm
protecting it by using this one more
thing on my desk is this blue yeti
microphone i use this for voiceovers for
my videos but not really for voice calls
or anything like that
so i only use it occasionally not all
the time but this is just something i
put on my desk as well under my desk is
where i hide the whole mess of cables
there are so many different cables that
i need to power up my workstation and i
have these two wire boxes in order for
me to store everything neatly and to add
a bit of an ambient glow to my setup i
have a lifx strip running along the edge
of my desk and i can use my phone to
control the colors and the brightness
and there you have it that was my 2021
work from home desk setup please let me
know in the comments below what your
favorite item is in the whole setup as
always please give this video a like if
you enjoyed it but yeah thank you for
watching and i'll see you next time bye
for now